to export to it i need to pay somebody
who wants to pay somebody
for my product to come out and that's
great so you need to pay four people
first to get your product out of this
corruption it's just corruption but if
all these people have to get together
and help each i mean i see how this
white
people are doing here what these white
guys are not great so this is what they
do so i met what some guys they're five
of them they said okay they didn't have
the money so what they did was they went
to the bank
each person had to go and apply for
credit card they each got two hundred
thousand two hundred to one so they
ended up with
one million run they took the one
million run credit card and then they
started the one farmer
he started planting lettuce after six
weeks he started harvesting like he's
made two million run he takes the two
million run
pay then they invested into the next
person by the end of six months all five
of them had already they had
farms fully operational but zimbabwes
don't want to do that zimbabwe don't
wanna but but specifically black
zimbabweans
is a black specifically black zimbabwe
because the white guys that are farming
here are the same guys that we've been
farming in zim
now when mugabe started sorting out his
black people they started running to
south africa
now this is where they are so the
problem is not that zimbabwe is bad
if zimbabwe is not passing but it's not
zimbabwe is rich it's great
we are to i mean when i say we i'm south
african black south africa but it's the
same
because we also don't help each other
trust me as blacks and africans we also
don't help each other
it's it's this you know there's this
pulliam down syndrome
i don't want to see eric uh succeeding
so i'm gonna make sure
that you know what i'm gonna be jealous
and then pull uh
that's the same same thing i always say
to ladies i say women will be five they
were not putting each other down
they will be very far same thing as what
the mermaids do
trust me if i had to get a piece of
friend didn't see scene
i'll be gone where would you market your
stuff if you're there if you're the
piece of land i'm now sitting i'm
sitting with four
expert companies as we speak right now
four expert companies that are saying
once you're ready please can we take
your purchase
okay so now and you know where they saw
my produce direct market floor
so now you've basically said to me
as we sit the three of us here you are
saying
if you've got money let's put money
together let's do this
but we do it big here's one two million
rand is required
here's what we do the golden rulings are
in for me whatever you do do it big
whatever anything that you wanna do if
you wanna plan spinach
go big you wanna plant beans go big
anything that you do go big because what
you then do
is you are so well known at the market i
mean look i'm only operating four
thousand five hundred square meters of
greenhouses on paper that's nothing
that's probably about
500 400 boxes a day i need to be sending
about
two to three thousand boxes a day to the
market and you will not you will find
buyers no no i have buyers that i'm not
even
that i'm not knowing they're making the
demands as we speak right now
fresh mark wants all this i've got a guy
who's in cape town he wants this i've
got mr machang who's in cleveland he
wants this
i've got guys that you chris they want
this